negli episodi precedenti diritto mike
c'è troppa gente non ci passo come
facciano cosa di in acqua
bye bye bye bye corri corri corri 82.000
mano costo gigante sul soffitto
no no no per avere omesso fosse un bug
non potete fare questo no ma falda
riesci subito ti prego e immediatamente
esci di qui c'è oggi al divano cade no
ragazzi dovete toglierle li avete
togliermi toglieteli toglietevi dalla
che cade il divano porca vacca
ok minchia non è morta meno male
io l'ho vista schiacciata non so come
faccio a essere viva
cioè se voi guardate la schiacciata
amata ma valissimo proprio non so come
faccia essere via impossibile e ho preso
store hobo ma non ho capito cosa serve
l'ho preso a caso c'è un'altra tv magro
sincronizzare governo aspetti che cambio
canale dovuta questo buttano punta l'on
e ce l'ho in mano come faccio io vengo
valore di buttare si sono poi gli fare
niente portiamoli cubo
ma col cubo in mano sto facendo
ok ci siamo non arriva mai alla porta
però di tutto ciò che non hai capito
non capisco cosa sto facendo io tutte le
volte faccio sta roba non lo capisco non
lo comprendo corro al ralenti salto non
arrivò mai la porta e poi mi si
teletrasporta fuori governo
spiegatemi in senso perché non l'ho
capito però sono quasi arrivato in tutto
questo c'è quasi la porta
celo celo la maniglia l'ho aperta ce
l'ho fatta giusta aperta e quindi
minchia lo slider né col cappello
[Musica]
paga
sta facendo la crisi si sta facendo
krypi ragazzi 9
porca the ring corri corri mafalda
corri minchia lo slider me ma cosa cosa
vedo
tuttora lenticolari mafalda se mai ne
vai che non c'è niente di là dove vai
porca vacca e non ci si può nascondere
sono morti già visti per forma guarda
che c'è il disegno di lui lì ma chi è
no ragazzi mafalda mafalda cosa fai no
no non me lo scegliete no no no vi prego
no vi prego ma vi prego non vi prego no
no
e diventata come gli altri bambini raga
è diventata lo spettro no mafalda no
grida mela pezzente maledetto schifoso
di uno spilungone dov'è dove sei doveri
da me la ridà mela dove brutto schifoso
ad un laido rita pena subito ecco ti
vengo a prendere ti prendo a pedate nel
culo flaccido che ti ritrovi porca vacca
ero ben teletrasporto quindi televisori
sono teletrasporti va bene ma ma quindi
non è morta né morta raga e sono
diventata c'è la presa e morta non è
morta no ragazzi non posso giocare io
sto gioco ancora se non milita sua morte
non è morta non è morta me l'ha fregata
lowes lander man porco del demonio dove
noi ragazzi c'è sta cosa qua non può
esistere lo dico cosa devo fare i posti
televisori devono continuare a entrare
la tv
entrò nella tv è la vera e proprio
perché dovresti attaccare una tv ad uno
stendino tra l'altro se posso
permettermi forse ai costanti sistema di
trasporti possa arrivare a quella torre
lì però mafalda ma la dovete ridare
ragazza
e vabbè non pensavo di buttare la giorno
va bene ok inside the televisore
no ragazzi c'è veramente di dover fidate
vela immediatamente porca vacca giù giù
ancora
mamma mia che storia o bob e chi era
quello che veramente chi è
se solo non l'avessi curiosato così
tanto questo non mi avrebbe rubato la
falda porco del demonio vedi a furia di
fare il figo che vuole fare le cose me
lanciato pure inter chieri dove stiamo
andando
meza nepalese un altro ospedale no c'è
un'altra tv posso entrare in questa qua
solito se come noi vediamo allora possa
accendere però
[Musica]
scusa scusa non si accetta perché non è
la tv per non è il telecomando per
questa tv o sì o forse devo salire e
spegnere quella di sopra che devo fare
ok lo accesa per il centro a ok quindi
adesso il telecomando remote control
possa accendere le televisioni e 3
trasportarmi figo ora qua devo accendere
quella dall'altra parte bellissima sta
cosa e tipo portale diventato adesso
parte qua c'è un'altra via non ce lo
troviamo a sì sì c'è un berretto nuovo
ho trovato il berretto da carabiniere ma
come commissario
cos'è che figata stato un carabiniere ok
ancora così ma chi li emette le grucce
ma kg con le pinze roberto credibile
sfondo le finestre like there is no
tomorrowland la spengo io come
lasciargli la scienza questa madonna che
però sta che sei posso lasciarti accesa
la tv mi conviene perché se tela spengo
credo dice qua posso uscire
tranquillamente senza badare lei sì
grazie arrivederci
c'è un balcone porca vacca devo
accendere questa deve entrare mila come
faccio allora 1
devo fare casino raga devo farla venire
di 4a così lei è andata di là ok
l'accento qua come veloce veloce yes
6 salve se ne frega niente che è uscito
un microbo dal tuo televisore non gliene
frega nulla anzi è stata la parte
migliore del programma secondo me perché
non è che succeda molti programmi varia
come li ha combinato la faccia c'è ma
che razza di roba era ragazzi sta tv e
mette un pelo di radiazioni di san tubo
catodico ho capito però anche qua la
vedo grigia
anzi noi ragazzi mi si ammazza si butta
giù
scommettete lavora che si ammazza
ammazza gli è bellissimo è rimasto
incastrato nel covo cascato 18
tantissimo mi dispiace ho fatto un
favore secondo me però berco demonio ho
rischiato chi ha tirati è che cacchio
tutti guardano la tv in mezzo alla
strada mi sembra giusto jolo ok
minchia ragazzi come questa pioggia
disastro e antonello confini che gioca
little nightmare è troppo tardi
ok
l'ho fatto prima ce la puoi fare col
telecomando in mano non so per quale
motivo gli ex non anche capito dove sono
finito ma sale sul divano pratico per
terra
ma basta co ste tv ma che ma che cazzo
vi ricordate che state a guardarli amici
abbiamo scendere questo però se lo
accendo poi il disastro ha però mi
sfondate la vetrina
ok allora accendo facendo quello e
spengo questa signori venite qua c'è
stata la tv accesa qua è là che c'è
barbara d'urso dove l'ha sfondata la
finestra che siete pazzi si sfonda e
piante per il culo
no non la sfondano sono io che devo
entrare la tv la sinistra ok ok non
avevo capito
sarebbe stato utile secondarie anche la
finestra esigenze e accendi ti va ora
quelli che guardano dalla nicchia
l'hanno sfondata nasconda nascondendo
tutto fratellino vabbè hanno sfondato
odiose scassata e adesso sì che la
sfoglia finestra è prima no come cacchio
è come che prima non si sfonda adesso si
sfonda il piano per il culo mica non
avete sfondato avevate ancora
televisione avete sfondato per me oggi è
quasi a stallone di voi
meno male che l'ipnotizza fanno la pipì
utilizzati così tanto
minchia raga pugno ma perché tiri fuori
la tv genere comando perché io sono il
telecomando ogni tanto è pazzo ma perché
lo fa vi giuro che non sul ghiaccio
hanno niente per quello questo il tasto
del telecomando perché ogni tanto lo
tira fuori mentre corrono ma che è a
forse con di prossimità dei televisori
rotti lavori in automatico
non so non sono un capitale let's go non
di là ok
faccio una porta graffia tissima mafalda
ma fa da sei tu mafalda ti prego torna
qui e quindi va da chi lo fa
no brutto schifoso flex e madonna senti
non tv a schiaffi a terra
madonna sono tipi a schiaffi a terra
amica sta arrivando stavo scherzando la
tipica schiaffi a primi la porta è morto
mi sono messo nascosto dietro non può
sapere dove sono
c'è lascia dovevo sfondare a porta lega
non magari non mi vede mi ha visto
[Musica]
madonna raga bellissima prova che chi ha
fatto veramente bene
ci hai fatto veramente dove concorre con
sull'ascia e devono sfondare la porta in
tempo però è fatto non si bada ne è
fatto veramente benissimo sto gioco
mafalda ti pigli ero prima o poi non so
come corri non so dove sto andando non
lo so ma dov'erano stati ragazzi
veramente luz lander man di tutto e per
tutto è proprio lui solo che ha una
faccia lui se guardate bene la gente non
ce l'aveva
se riusciamo a passare lì senza che
nessuno revealed alla porta in fondo che
pure storta ma guarda che in regia
pazzesca già sto cacchio di gioco ma
guarda che immagine incredibile mamma
mia
c'è veramente fatto e la madonna però
pensiamo dopo la regia prima deve uscire
ok tuttora lenti e tuttora lenti quando
succede sta roba esalta c'è un treno
cosa quindi socio c'è un treno come è
possibile
c'è un treno a caso con gente scomparsa
dentro però non rendermi non mi segue
più non ho capito se una posta in questa
è una volta me lo dice lo zio favi che
una busta in questo non lo posso
allontanare ma non mi posso mai
allontanare
speriamo che mafalda stia fuggendo nel
mentre che si faceva stare male che c'è
lui figlia ovunque è un fenomeno cazzo
sei usain bolt che corri gioco che fai
arrivare al governo che arrivo io è
veramente un genio cioè come se no vi
sono incastrato nel divano
mamma mia come supermario punti lo ha
tirati la tira tira tira giù giù chiesto
allora per il ciuccio che la prima porta
le famosissime porte che si aprono
tirando la corda
chi non l'ha mai vista ok staccati in
tutto e per tutto se noi ce l'abbiamo
nel culo ecco perfetto e staccato figli
amico a piglià v6 coraggio suo partito
col treno fatto una leva a caso ha fatto
partire il treno incazza la leva del
freno allontanarsi dalla linea gialla
il treno trenitalia 22 arca
travolta e ad un'attesa è stata immane
sono vivo a posto tirato una testata
secolare altre novità tutto ok con morto
perché molto meno però fa niente
no il telecomando seesmic jato mi chiama
di schiena sono entrato vecchio perché è
stata una schierata fortissima al treno
c'è una scala enorme nicchia con la mi
porta in cima a torre o no
mamma mia e quindi ben scaliamo guarda
che roba
madonna della scala gigante non vedeva
una scala così grossa da metalli gear
solid 3 pochi colgono lecite di metalli
e vero non so neanche dove stiamo
andando ragazzi però non ha le fogne
certamente un treno che passa era lara è
l'ala m quella contraria la m
impossibile ok
non era assolutamente la scala per la
torre madonna di dio che che
inquadratura incredibile e quindi
no no no no non posso fare niente sono
mi sono arreso si è anche fermato si sta
inquinando sto facendo niente io s'è
tolto il cappello no
il cappello da carabiniere ma lo posso
più chiara del biglietto per la metro
no sono morto mafalda entrò nel bouquet
di harry potter
la madonna
l'ho fatto io posso respingerti col
potere delle mie mani perché tu non puoi
passare ero troppo scontato da dire ma
l'unico schiatta è schiatta io posso
respingerti perché nelle mani chol
amuchina
la cosa sto facendo non lo so
incredibile devi schiantarsi io non ho
capito mori toast distrutto tutti gli
horcrux cosa minchia vuoi fare dato che
si scorge tutto è un po una versione è
un mix tra de croo kidman e slider man
non è che vi basta
e quindi e io amo col cappello
va bene che sei nello ma non sarai di me
più bello mamma mia ma che poeta morto
ho vinto e morto come volte s'è
scomposto con le voldemort guarda che
non ero spoiler ed al quale c'è un po di
harry potter ha potuto slang harry
potter le crew che invece quasi riguardo
i pali della luce si piegano al mio
volere torre di merda a dice anche lei
dice anche signori anelli torre esplodi
posso buttare sulla torta
no ragazzi sto male sto malissimo
sono arrivato all'entrata della torre
picchia praga ma che mamma mia ma che
figata che gioco incredibile impallidito
sbloccato certo la porta e la porta la
porta a porta la porta la porta la porta
la porta alla porta la porta a porta
posso trovare mafalda la palla trovo
mafalda ho battuto lo slider meno preso
la metro
ho fatto un casino ho perso il mio
cappello da carabiniere ma ci sono la
falda c'è la gravità va dentro vostre no
capitana
quindi è entro lì dentro
entro in quello che mi si apre che
dovevo teletrasporto nome ragazzi ma che
cacchio è non so con che fisica si
reggano ste scale però va bene quanto ed
ha visto come dino proprio da lì lo
stile è quello scopo di tali da porta a
porta a porta 2 anche porta al normale
torna indietro come anti chamber 9 vado
avanti che dovrebbe proseguire laddove
da dove arriva la musica è colmato
geniale geniale geniale geniale mica non
ci sarei mai arrivato
cioè ci sono arrivato ma per caso
madonna quindi dovevo seguire la musica
e quindi anche qua aspetto che ci sia la
musica qua qua e la musica è l'unica
porta mi sembra difficile che ci sia
nelle altre esche
meno male che un e cuffie ed è più
facile da capire quale la porta con la
musica
questa no questa chiusa come centro
mafalda ragazzi in tutto questo è
sparita perché mafalda prima vista va se
ci avete fatto caso mi stava di cui mi
stava guidando all'inizio mi guidava
c'era avevo lo spettro che mi guidava ma
non ho ben capito come sia stato
possibile tutto questo qua picchia
ci vorranno anni di terapia mafalda sei
tu no cosa fai fai le dita lunghissime
con quel dito medio puoi mandare a fare
in culo chiunque in maniera incredibile
per favore ma fa da mi ricordo ci sono
io guardami vietata michigan che è
successo cosa è successo premi per
chiamare
[Musica]
ma viene porca vacca nome ragazzi che
calcio è successo è diventata un gigante
anche lei tutto nostro
quindi è lo slider man che rende mostri
le persone e perché lei non mi fa niente
perché si ricorda di me ma posso farla
tornare come prima di tutto questo c'è
un martello le spa col carillon dello
space 2 perché magari ti faccio tornare
normale foglio lodo sulla mano e basta
sto coso nicchia spaventata un attimo
che è successo quindi l'ha trasformata
in un mostro che è successo
mafalda seguimi no work a di
cassare no io lo facevo per il tuo bene
mafalda mafalda non mi riconosci sono io
non va riconosciuto solo noi ma come il
fatto che fai non riconosce mila farlo
abbiamo passato un sacco insieme abbiamo
distrutto il mani di manichini abbiamo
preso le bobine orco demonio li preso
ascensori saltato tu mi chiedevi la mano
mammamia rosso anche come ho fatto a
salvarmi e mafalda livello di vedere no
non la pagano poi non riconoscermi non
puoi non puoi aprì la porta per favore
la porta lì a destra sta alla porta una
porta cioè fatto tutto tranne che da
togliere a tavolino
minchia ma cosa è successo
cosa è successo mafalda cosa efficiente
e niente io mi sono mi b sono solo io
non potrò più dormire come prima questo
le porte di prima qualcosa di dalì
spacca tutto mi sa che mi sente però
solo spacco spacca ma arrivò mafalda io
lo faccio per il tuo bene devi tornare
come prima
minchia devo spaccare il carillon ma
smettila
magari se glielo spacco torna come prima
regata
ma la vedo dura però solo me come faccio
dai calma lo faccio per te sono le video
avvicinare abbastanza in modo tale che
lei li prenda cioè non che non mi prenda
ma che mi segua seguimi perché poi mi
dai trasporto rapido e semi
teletrasporto riesco a prendere il coso
ok me la mia testa era diverso
ce l'ha fatta ce l'ho fatta ho messo
un'ora ha idee e lo spacca spero di
avergli e l'ho spaccato non lo so
minchia raga
mamma mia che combattimento assurdo è
stata la roma ma poi a mafalda cioè come
fai che succede qua tutto lento porca
vacca non sono finite tutto in slow mo
spacca la porta mafalda mafalda e lo
faccio per il tuo bene
è un'attività simile porca
bellissimo ce l'ho fatta al celo celo
celo celo celo celo celo quindi inizio
faccio così
va bene e poi faccio cosa
mamma mia mamma mia che giocata che è
giocata che è giocata incredibile
incredibile proprio lui lo spaccato sta
a fare no due ore di martedì lasciate su
stappare le che cacchio lo faccio per te
mafalda
lo faccio per te mannaggia mollano sta
roba che pulsa in giro
mafalda togli le tue mani da lì fidati
lo faccio
[Risate]
va bene basta dire di no urlo poco prima
di tirare una volta finale o che
all'arrivo fino al tappeto e poi urlo e
poi dovrebbe togliere le mani questa è
la botta finale sicuro
eccola ace
heiter e l'ho fatta vince di nuovo di
oggi attira generata un'altra un'altra
mori c'erano lei e mafalda forin amori
carli è tornata normale è tornata
normale eccola mafalda sono io guarda
cosa ho fatto sono stato bravissimo ma
fa al dato distrutto
eccomi sono io sono io ti prego braccia
minimi che ti ricordi di medici che
siamo amici
tutto a posto
e tornata normale ma che non ci credo ci
sia l e lei e lei si ricorda mafalda non
ripresa lo ripresa ragalo ripresa lo
ripresa lo ripresa lo ripresa
minchia sta arrivando il blog
e vabbè ma il sorrento
come muoio madonna raga l'agar agar agar
agar agar agar mafalda una mano per
favore non lo so io è mica il ponte di
casa tour porco demonio
entra nella porta no mica mi si spacca
tutto adesso voglio io non ci credo non
ci credo non ci credo
mafalda la mano minchia incredibile
veloci veloci che sta accadendo tutto
qua
minchia non mi lascia la mano non mi
lascia la mano mafalda
[Musica]
no scusatemi ma come
ma sto pezzo di me non ho capito o 60
due episodi che le salvo il culo a
destra marco adesso spaccato il curry ma
cosa no non ci credo non scusate mi
dissocio
cioè si dissocia lei si curano io ma che
cacchio succede
no ragazzi sono in mare di blob perché
mafalda mi ha mai mollato la mano sta
come si può essere i family friendly una
situazione del genere non si può ragazzi
sono in un intestino cioè cosa diavolo
spiegami ma perché c'è una sedia
no ragazzi non sto capendo perché mi ha
lasciato la mano perché
no rega
adesso sono lì e non posso più uscire
o che ancora vivo
[Musica]
sono segregato nell'oblio lei è uscita
lei è uscita dalla porta bianca sono
cresciuto invecchiato qua sono io quello
sì per forza nel nulla e compagnato sono
cresciuto io lingue così e quindi
beh sono diventate una persona di
dimensioni normali almeno quello era un
microbo
[Musica]
e quindi
immagino che io non lo posso più
controllare bit mista che è così e cos'è
successo
lei riuscita se fatti i cazzi suoi
no non ci credo non ci credo
non ci voglio credere
[Applauso]
ma che picchia di trippe ma quando mai
ero io lo slider man fin dall'inizio
porca 3 muta pelle d'oca lega ma che
picchia di trama incredibile che gioco
assurdo che gioco pazzesco ma che no
rega incredibile incredibile incredibile
ma cosa sto giocando pazzesca sta roba
ma che trama ma non ci posso credere non
ci posso credere ma che idea pazzesca
ero io lo stesso tornato indietro nel
tempo cioè tutte quelle i portali quindi
c'è anche il tempo di mezzo quindi ero
io che sono invecchiato alla fine ce
l'ha fatta perché mi ha mollato la mano
tentato di riprenderla io e di farle
quello che lei ha fatto a me a
condannandomi pazzesco che trova
incredibile mamma mia
no ragazzone cioè è un finale del di
merda e nonni che brutto nel senso che è
un finale cattivo cioè nel senso che
avrei preferito un finale gioioso che
non lo è però che trama
mamma mia che gioco questo era un gioco
con la g maiuscola bellissimo dieci
volte il primo ma dieci volte anche più
bello di un sacco di altri geni che ho
fatto
ragazzi se la combatte con inside suo
nome a livello di trama è meglio non si
può dire niente meglio a livello di
trama che forse in inside variava un po
di più il gameplay suoi facevi un po più
di cose che poi io volevo ti volevo dire
una cosa non lo so è questa è una mia
idea ma siccome a livello di tempo non
si è capito più una mazza
forse sì come intel nightmares 1 c'è il
protagonista che al impermeabile giallo
elite e laives 2 che mafalda che ho
chiamato e così al impermeabile giallo
forse mafalda e il personaggio
principale di del di tele1 quindi
cronologicamente questo sta messo prima
e poi c'è di the light nessuno a livello
di trama perché il personaggio
principale di tele nessuno è uguale a
mafalda quindi magari lei può fantastico
giuro incredibile quindi signori spero
che il video era serie vi siano piaciuti
come al solito sorriso bisogna solo
questo è un mi piace anche vari social
che come noi adottata da studiare se non
siete persi si chiedevano come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video bello ragazzi
[Musica]